Hey, everybody.
Welcome to Rollback.
Rollback is my way of introducing powerful,
enlightening,
and evergreen conversations
from the prehistoric pre-video days of the podcast
right here on YouTube for the very first time.
Conversations like this one from July of 2015
with former NFL star, David Carter,
AKA the 300 pound vegan.
Like most athletes, David grew up eating tons of meat,
fully adhering to the conventional mythology
that in order to become muscle,
you must consume muscle.
But as his career matured,
David became plagued by a variety
of persistent, chronic injuries,
including arthritis and tendonitis,
ailments he simply could not overcome
that left him sidelined
despite the best sports medicine
and rehabilitative resources of the NFL
at his disposal.
And so,
through a series of rather improbable events
in February of 2014,
David made this rather radical
and quite controversial decision,
which was to adopt a 100% plant-based diet.
As a result,
to the great surprise of his coaches,
his trainers, his teammates,
every single one of those nagging, persistent injuries
mysteriously corrected themselves
and ultimately vanished altogether.
All his numbers in the weight room went up.
He found himself quicker, more agile,
and more responsive than ever.
And perhaps most important to David,
no living thing had to die in order for him to thrive.
It's a truly special exchange
with an exceptional human being
that explores a typical day in the life of the NFL,
it's a peek into the typical NFL diet,
what he eats now on a daily basis,
and tons more.
I sincerely hope you enjoy our discussion
and look forward to your thoughts
in the comments section below.
So you're writing a book right now?
We're getting ready to start writing a cookbook.
Oh, are you?
Yeah,
'cause we're working with Lighter and all that stuff,
We'll talk about it later.
Yeah.
We can talk about it now.
No, I was just like,
oh, don't want to use all the questions.
No, it's cool.
We're already rolling, man.
Oh.
(men laughing)
Okay, we could edit it out if you want to,
but.
That's fine.
Yeah, man.
That's exciting.
A cookbook, huh?
Yeah, we're, you know,
a lot of people are asking a lot of questions like,
you know, what are you eating?
Where can I get my protein from?
How the hell are you getting 10,000 calories in a day?
Or I eat like,
well, I eat like 300 plus grams of protein a day.
They're like, "How are you getting that on a vegan diet?"
So it only makes sense to put.
Yeah, of course.
A vegan cookbook out there.
Well, I don't know if you guys know,
but we just had a cookbook that just came out.
Yeah.
I'll give you guys a copy of it.
Don't let me forget.
Yeah.
'Cause I was about to run out and get one.
(man laughing)
I got one with your name on it.
Thanks.
Cool, man.
Well thanks for making the time to come on over here
and do this.
Thanks, man.
I appreciate you having me on this show.
It means a lot.
Oh, cool.
Well, I've been following your journey from afar for a while
and it's quite an inspiring story.
It's a unique story,
and I think it's an important story.
I mean, there's a lot of similarities in our journey,
and you know, some distinct differences as well,
and I kind of want to get into all of it, man,
but I think the best way to just kick it off
is like, let's just go back to the beginning, dude.
Like, where does football start with you?
Where'd you grow up?
Like, how did you kind of,
you know, blaze this path
into becoming a college football player and beyond
into the NFL?
Oh, okay.
Well, we're taking it way back.
Yeah, it's way back.
Well, let's set the stage.
No, I hear ya.
Well, I have a brother and we both play football.
So we started in high school,
we started in Pop Warner, like five.
You grew up out here?
Yeah.
Grew up in Los Angeles.
Just said that I'm a Los Angeles Native.
Grew up in Southern Los Angeles.
My brother, I have a sister, and my two parents.
And so my brother and I started playing Pop Warner football
at Crenshaw High School,
this Pop Warner team.
And we were defensive lineman there
and then on to high school,
and you know, the basics.
College, I went to UCLA.
Did you have a good high school football team?
Yeah, we went to, we won.
We were pretty good.
We went,
we won the,
man, was a long time ago.
Hard for me to remember.
Come on, man.
What are you?
26, 27?
27.
(men laughing)
You're literally half my age almost.
I know, right?
Come on.
But we were with Kaiser High School.
We had pretty good football team.
My brother and I, we were known as the book ends.
I played the left defensive end,
the strong side defensive end.
My brother played the right side defensive end,
and we went to win on a lot of games.
We were like 10 and 12, so that's pretty good.
We didn't even win the championship,
but that's pretty damn good, you know?
And what's he doing now?
He's in the NFL too.
Oh, he is?
Yeah.
I didn't know that now.
Wow
(man laughing)
Wow, who's he play with?
Right now, he's a free agent I think.
You think?
You don't know what team your brother plays for?
(men chuckling)
Unless he just got signed,
but unless he just got signed.
But yeah, he went on,
he played with the Steelers for two years,
with the Colts one year,
at the Bengals another year.
So we both actually got drafted at the same time.
Oh, I didn't know that.
Wow.
Yeah,
we were playing.
Both defensive linemen?
Yeah, he was a defensive end.
I was a interior defensive lineman.
And we actually got drafted on the same day.
We're the first brothers to get drafted
on the same day in the NFL.
That's pretty cool.
Yeah.
That's pretty awesome.
So, hold on,
wait, he's older or he's younger?
He's younger than me.
He's younger.
But in college,
I had a red shirt year 'cause I wasn't big enough.
I was like 250, 260 in college my freshman year.
So they were like,
oh yeah, you got a red shirt,
and red shirt a year.
And then, yeah,
but he didn't have to red shirt
'cause he was playing a smaller position,
like an outside linebacker.
Defensive end position.
Did he go to UCLA also?
No, he went to Fresno State.
So he went, he did pretty well.
That's pretty special, man.
So, I mean, are your parents still around?
Yeah.
Yeah?
So that must have been a big moment for them.
Both their sons getting drafted on the same day.
It's amazing.
Yeah,
they're pretty excited.
A couple people passed out at the draft party
like, oh my gosh!
(men laughing)
They both got drafted at the same time.
Oh gee!
That's amazing.
Yeah.
So, alright,
so you're playing at UCLA,
and I mean, did you have a sense that
you were headed for the big show?
I mean, was that,
I mean obviously that's your dream, right?
I mean, was it looking like it was gonna work,
or how does that all play out?
You know, I didn't know
if I was gonna get drafted to the league,
but I did pretty well my senior year,
junior-senior year,
and ended up going in the fifth round, sixth round.
Sixth round.
He's looking,
his wife.
(man laughing)
She keeps the stats?
Yeah.
Sixth round.
My brother went fifth round and I went sixth round,
but yeah, you know,
I ended up doing well after college.
I played defensive end and interior tackle.
When I got to the league, I got drafted six round.
They were like, "Oh, he's not six round draft."
They didn't think I was gonna last too long.
But I ended up starting my rookie year.
Oh, you did?
At the Cardinals.
At the Arizona Cardinals at nose tackle.
And I was undersized.
Most defensive nose tackles are like 340 pounds,
and I was 300 starting at the.
What do you attribute that to?
I mean, did you have some kind of extra speed or agility?
Yeah, it was quick.
I'm very quick for my size.
I wasn't vegan then.
Yeah, I know we're gonna get into that.
Don't worry.
But very quick for my size,
and very strong,
and I did very well,
made a lot of plays, a lot of stats.
So yeah, my first sack was Manning and the Giants.
Wow.
And so, yeah,
it's pretty good.
How many games in was that?
I don't remember what game that was.
Paige might know.
Paige, do you remember?
(men laughing)
How long have you guys been together?
Oh wow,
since before, it's like sophomore year of college.
Oh, nice.
Yeah.
College sweethearts.
Yeah, it's been a long time.
Yeah, and you've been kind of a journeyman
in the NFL.
I mean, you played for a bunch of teams.
You played for the Cardinals, and then the Cowboys,
and then the Raiders,
and then the Jaguars, right?
Yeah.
So you have
a pretty good sense for how the NFL functions
for how these various teams operate,
and you know, kind of, you know, what the NFL is all about.
And I'm interested as somebody who, you know,
I watch football.
I don't watch a ton of football,
but you know, I just see it on television.
I don't know that many guys that play in the NFL.
And I think it would be,
you know, I'd love to know a little bit about
what a real day in the life of an NFL player is.
'Cause I think we have this
perhaps kind of hyper,
perhaps exaggerated sense of like how sexy it is,
and it's just sort of like all fly,
and you're all up in the club and throwing money around,
and everybody's living in a huge mansion,
driving a Ferrari.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
I think that's
sort of a conventional idea of the typical football player.
I mean, but what is it really like?
Well, it is, you're right, it is kind of sexy,
but it is hard work at the same time.
You know, you're working out all day.
Like, a lot of people sit behind the desk all day and work.
You're working out all day, every day.
You wake up at,
your workouts start at like five o'clock in the morning
and then you have like four hours of meetings
and watching films, and studying your opponent,
and learning plays.
And the playbooks are,
the playbooks are thicker than like calculus textbooks.
And they're huge.
And you have to remember all those plays,
otherwise you're not playing.
And so it's very,
it is a lot of hard work.
And then not to mention the beating that you're taking
all day.
When you're working out,
I'm talking about working out,
I'm talking about practices,
and practices are hard.
They're tedious and a lot of stress on the body.
You're going up,
say for example in my position, the defensive line,
you're going up against two other guys that are your size
or bigger,
and you're doing that all day every day.
And then after that you have to rehab
and you know how that goes after.
So you're trying to reset bones
that have been like knocked outta place.
You have to go to a chiropractor,
or you have to stretch out muscles that have been sprained,
or they're bruised
and you got,
it's a lot of hard work.
Yeah.
Yeah, I think you said in one of your posts
or somewhere on your website
that every day of practice
is like being in a 60 mile an hour car crash.
Yeah, man, that's definitely true.
And you feel it,
and you feel it in your joints
and all that stuff.
A lot of guys end up having like tendonitis and all that
just from the constant banging.
Yeah, you're never,
it's never like you wake up and feel good, right?
There's always something.
Yeah.
That's off,
or a pain, or an injury.
Yeah.
At the very minimum, right?
At the very minimum.
A lot of guys get really good at kind
of just like phasing, like tuning it out of their mind.
Like, oh, it's not pain,
It's, you know, what's really pain?
Are you bleeding?
Right.
Can you walk?
Then you not hurt.
(man chuckling)
Right, right.
You just sore,
but really you have a slipped disc
or something like that.
(men chuckling)
And I would imagine along with that,
there's all the pressure
of trying to hold onto your job, right?
Like, so you're not gonna necessarily be forthright
about something that's bugging you.
I mean, you don't want to create the perception
that you're injured.
No, definitely not.
'Cause the team will use that against you
if you're injured or something like that.
Like for example, this is a perfect example,
team doctors,
you know, you go to doctor to get help,
and have 'em look at you and tell you know what's wrong
and how to fix it,
but the doctors don't work for you.
Yeah, there's no privilege, right?
They go right to the coach.
Yeah, the doctors work for the team.
So if you tell him,
if something's wrong with you,
they're not gonna help you be like,
"All right man, don't worry about it.
He'll get back out.
You're gonna be good."
Like, no, they're gonna tell the coaches,
and then if-
Yeah, so he's on the out.
Yeah, get him out of there,
and that's how that works.
So, yeah, you gotta,
it is very political.
It's a game.
It's a chess game and you have to know how to play it.
Definitely.
What are some of the political mistakes
that maybe you made early on that you learned from,
in kind of navigating how the teams function
and how you relate to the coach?
Hmm.
Political mistakes?
I don't know about political mistakes, but.
Or just maybe things you witnessed,
or along the way.
Political mistakes,
or not mistakes, political things.
For example, guys who get the big contracts,
they can do no wrong.
So, I've seen a guy like,
I don't know,
guy spit in another guy's face,
or something like that.
Or try to knock another guy who's got so much money,
you know,
the guy who's got all the money,
try to knock another guy off of,
you know, hurt him.
The coach sees it,
they don't do anything about it
because you know the guys.
They're too invested in that guy.
Yeah, too invested in that guy.
So, and that's how, you know, it's an investment.
They pay that guy a hundred million dollars,
they're not gonna get rid of him.
They're gonna get rid of the guy who is, you know,
who's trying to come up and take that guy's job.
They'll trade him.
That's another thing.
If someone's doing really well,
they pay the guy a hundred million dollars,
they're not gonna get rid of the guy
who got a hundred million dollars.
They're gonna get rid of that guy,
the guy who's up and coming.
Right, and after playing
under a variety of different NFL coaches,
what would you,
how would you characterize the better coaches?
Like, what is it that the better coaches are doing
that the other coaches aren't?
Like, how would you qualify
a great coach from an average coach?
A great coach allows the players to play,
you know?
If someone, the best person's gonna play.
Yeah, on any team you're gonna have that
where the guy who's got
the a hundred million dollar contract is gonna play,
but the good coaches find a place for someone to play.
And they keep it simple for the players
to do what they gotta do,
'cause when you're out there flying around
in a hundred miles an hour,
you know, you're not trying to think,
you're just trying to act,
and you're trying to make moves,
make things happen.
And the coaches realize what's going on.
They understand the dynamic of the team.
They know how to,
that's one.
That's a really important thing.
They know how to keep a team, a team, you know?
It starts, you have to make it like a family first.
A friendship.
A lot of coaches like to make it so competitive
that there's so much tension in the locker room
and on the field
trying to compete for positions
that guys are just stressed out
and you can't operate under those conditions.
Yeah, undermines the bigger goal,
which is the team winning, right.
Definitely.
Yeah, I had this guy, Michael Gervais,
on the podcast.
He's a sports psychologist who works with Pete Carroll
and the Seahawks.
He was talking about
Pete brought him on to help create
a positive, team oriented environment
and also to instill practices of mindfulness,
and visualization, and meditation,
which I know are things that you practice and are into,
but maybe our slightly off kilter
for the average football player.
And it was really interesting talking to him
'cause he talked about how
basically his goal was to create an environment
where each player could bring out the best in them.
So it's about overcoming
that kind of inherent competitiveness
where everybody's worried about their job
to create a unity around the larger goal.
Exactly.
And they've been
really successful with that, right?
Take that recipe and repeat that, you know?
Yeah, I like Pete, man.
He, like you said, he's very-
You're not supposed to say that as a UCLA guy.
I know, man.
But I know,
I thought about that before I said it.
No one's listening.
I had to say it.
But hey, he won,
he wins games,
and like you said, he's a SC coach,
old SC coach.
He beat us when I was at UCLA,
but he wins games,
and every single player that I've met
that I know that's played under him, they love that guy.
And, you know, he makes it,
he sets an environment
where people can wanna come to work every day,
and they want to come work out,
and they want to play their hardest,
and put their neck on the line for 'em.
And, you know, that's how you win games.
And you don't have to create
a super competitive environment,
because guys already know that their jobs are on the line,
that they know that they're trying to beat the next man.
So, you know, that's why I respect the way he coaches
and what he's doing.
And then I, you know,
I love him, man.
Yeah, I mean, it's not a zero sum game, right?
Like, if your approach as a player is to say,
I'm gonna play my heart out,
but I'm also gonna do my best
to bring out the best in the guy standing right next to me.
Or, you know, my teammate who's right to my left
or my right.
Everybody wins.
Yeah.
But, you know,
the human psyche doesn't always operate that way.
Yeah.
It should.
I know.
(man chuckling)
Yeah.
And how did you
kind of handle the mental aspects of having,
of kind of bouncing around
from a bunch of different teams
and having to relocate, and all of that?
How did that go for you?
It's stressful,
but you know, that's like,
again, that's part of the game.
That's the job, right?
So you just gotta kind of roll with the punches
and prepare,
and be just as prepared as you possibly can.
We don't buy a home anywhere.
We just rent
and now we're setting up a home where we are now.
But, you know, you just gotta kind of just stay on your toes
and be ready to move.
But, you know, that's how the game goes.
Right, right, right.
Yeah.
So walk me through
the typical diet pre-vegan as an NFL player.
Oh man.
All right.
I know you love
your barbecue and that's what you grew up on.
Yeah, I did.
Yeah.
I grew up at a barbecue restaurant my family owned.
Oh, wow.
Yeah.
And we had a farm.
A farm?
Yeah, my grandpa would go out there
and ring the chicken's neck
and then we would eat it for breakfast.
Wow, where's the farm?
It was in Oklahoma and my aunt owned it.
We would drive out every summer
and go out there and spend the summer in Oklahoma.
And yeah, it was crazy.
A total 180 from what I am now.
But the pre-game diet,
it was just kind of just basically,
I didn't know anything about nutrition before being vegan,
but it was just basically eat whatever, man.
People were,
I was eating ice cream.
Most people do that.
It just, actually as a matter fact,
the night before the game, you stay in the hotel.
The team serves hot wings, and spaghetti,
oily meat sauce, and all that stuff,
and all kind of crap.
And like I said, ice cream shakes,
that's the worst thing you can have before a game, right?
Like, would you ever drink that before a,
the night before a marathon?
Uh uh.
No,
but that's the pre-game.
And then the day before, I mean, the day of,
it's pasta and super dry steak,
and it's been like that on every team.
Pasta and super dry steak.
Like, it's so hard to cut,
and like A1 steak sauce.
And then you go out there and you play your game.
And then during the week
when you're just training,
similar, a version of that?
Yeah, during the week,
like for example when I was on the Cardinals,
I forget the name of the restaurant they had catering in,
but it was, or we would get like Papados.
They would have catering.
Papados is all fried shrimp,
and fried alligator,
and fried everything.
Everything is fried.
There's team nutritionist, right?
Yeah.
They're bringing in fried food?
I mean, it doesn't matter if you're like,
whatever diet you're on,
everybody pretty much agrees
that a bunch of fried food is no good.
You guys are professional athletes.
Yeah.
And then there's some teams that
the nutritionist actually,
the nutritionist does what they're supposed to do.
And the nutritionist bring in
a lot of fruits and veggies,
but then they bring in like yogurt,
and all that stuff,
and being a vegan, I'm against all that.
But, you know,
people think that that's what you're supposed to have,
and that's good for you and all that.
And it's really bad for you,
and it's hurting you.
It's amazing that at that level
of professional sports
that that's kind of how it functions.
You know, I just was at,
a couple months ago
I went and spoke at the Olympic Training Center.
I spent a couple days there,
and in the cafeteria at the Olympic Training Center
in Colorado Springs
where all the top athletes
and all these Olympic sports come and train,
the cafeteria,
it just unlimited soda,
unlimited soft serve ice cream,
like all this junk food.
And I was like, what is going on?
Like, if anything this should be the place
where at least there's an opportunity
where you have these athletes that are
kind of cloistered in this place for a short period of time,
you could educate them.
I'm not saying like,
you and I are plant based,
but at least get rid of the soda
and the crappy processed food.
Yeah, but you know what?
What it comes down to is where's their money coming from?
Yeah.
Well, Coke is like,
McDonald's is the number one sponsor of the Olympics.
Right.
Right, McDonald's is also in hospitals,
and they're paying hospitals too.
McDonald's.
All right, let's not get into that.
We can get into that, man.
I know.
I talk about that stuff all the time, but.
Yeah.
You and I
know what's up with that.
Yeah, definitely.
All right,
so the latest team that you're on is the Jaguars, right?
And so when was that was?
Yeah, that was last year.
And then it ended, man,
when a running back hit me in the knee,
popped my knee really bad.
Tore an MCL,
and then I rehab on that.
But I healed pretty quickly.
So, but right now,
but that's got me in a spot right now.
I'm a free agent,
and I'm just waiting for camp to start
and then I'm gonna be on the team during camp.
For the Jaguars?
Well, for whatever team.
I see.
'Cause
that's how it goes.
Just waiting for,
you're waiting for your agent to call you.
Yeah.
Basically.
Yeah, but I did really well
when I was with the Jags.
So I put up some good numbers
and showed some good film and all that stuff,
so it's looking really good right now.
Yeah, I want to get into that
in a little bit more detail
'cause there's kind of an interesting story there
that relates to this lifestyle shift
that you have embraced.
So, you know, where does that begin?
I know Paige is a long time vegan,
vegetarian, vegan, Paige?
What's that?
Vegetarian.
Shift to vegan.
So Paige, were you vegetarian in college?
You were?
First year.
First year she was a meat eater,
and she read a,
the book's title is called "Skinny Bitch."
Yeah, "Skinny Bitch," right.
It's a good book.
(man chuckling)
Yeah, I know the book.
Yeah, Rory Friedman.
Yeah.
And that was, that kind of kick started everything
and everything, so, yeah.
But I mean,
you're playing ball.
Yeah
That's cool for her.
But like, that's not gonna be your trip.
Yeah, man.
I was like, man, you can forget that.
I'm not gonna.
(men laughing)
Yeah, right.
You want me to throw the?
You cannot afford to be a skinny bitch.
Right, I can't be.
That's the opposite
of what you're trying to do.
Exactly.
That's funny.
But yeah, man.
So she went vegan,
like I said, I was like, okay, good job.
You know, you can do that by yourself.
I'm gonna still keep eating this meat
and keep eating chicken.
I was eating four pieces of chicken in one sitting,
and, you know, huge 84 ounce steaks and all that stuff.
We would go out to eat.
And in college you were pushing what?
Like, 260?
No, that's my freshman year.
Freshman year.
The senior year of college
I was like 305.
Okay.
So, but yeah man, I was just eating whatever.
Right.
And you just carry that into the NFL,
and that's how you're playing,
and then something happens.
And then,
so got released from Arizona,
and then I was at the Cowboys,
and I got released from there.
I kept losing weight and I was hurting.
I had injuries.
They were just piling up.
Why do you think you were losing weight?
I don't know, man.
I was like 285-290,
and I couldn't get my weight back up.
But I was injured.
I had shoulder pain
'cause an old injury was coming back from college
where I had dislocated my right shoulder.
And then it was just kept getting worse,
and it was at the Cardinals too.
It started hurting then.
That's when it started hurting.
I had nerve damage in my right arm.
I couldn't feel my index finger,
middle finger, and ring finger,
and part of my thumb on my right hand.
Couldn't ball a fist.
They had me on this huge brace
and it would come basically from my elbow
all the way down to like the knuckles of my right hand.
And like, when I would try to hit someone,
I couldn't really have no power in it.
It was just like a limp.
And I was just playing.
But I was still playing and I was still doing well.
But like I said.
When you can't
exert yourself,
then you're not able to work out to your potential, right?
So I would imagine that had something to do
with losing some of the muscle mass.
Yeah, definitely.
But, and then got released,
and I finished the year out.
It started,
after I left it alone, it started healing up and everything.
But then going,
I went to the Cowboys and I was playing there,
and I got released from the Cowboys
'cause I was still,
my weight, I couldn't get it back up again.
I was stuck at 285-290.
And then I went to,
that's after I got released from the Cowboys,
I went to-
Raiders.
No, not there yet.
We're not there yet.
All right.
Now we were watching, we were in Dallas,
we were in our apartment,
we were binge watching Netflix,
all the vegan documentaries on Netflix.
(man laughing)
What a night, right?
Right.
So we were watching-
I take it this is Paige's idea?
No, no.
Well, it was mine.
I'm a little nerd.
I'm a nerd on the inside.
But what motivated you
to even wanna watch those documentaries to begin with?
Yeah, Paige.
Okay.
But we were watching,
we were watching "Forks Over Knives,"
one of the many that we watched,
and the doc was on there,
and he was talking about how,
at the time I was suffering.
Let me go back.
At the time I was suffering from tendonitis.
Excuse me.
And I would soak in the bathtub,
and I would try to lift myself up out of the bathtub
and it felt like somebody at would take a bat to my elbows.
And I just, I would like almost collapse.
The pain was so intense and so sharp.
And it was tendonitis.
Are you getting injections for that
on a battery of meds, or?
Yeah, I had,
they were giving me, not injections,
but they were giving me Celebrex,
or Napersan, or something like that.
They were like, "It's just tendonitis," you know,
it's nothing."
"The only way you can get rid of that is Celebrex."
And Celebrex, man, that stuff's so bad for you.
Like, I hope I don't get sued for saying that,
but that stuff's so bad for you.
Causes heart problems and all that kind of crap.
But anyways,
and it wasn't doing anything.
And arthritis too.
And arthritis.
Arthritis.
Yeah, arthritis,
high blood pressure probably from the medication
and what I was eating.
But you know that stuff, man, it's so bad.
At age like, 25 or?
That's the most scary part, right?
And I'm like, why,
how the hell do I have high blood pressure,
tendonitis, and arthritis?
Or like, I feel like arthritis coming on.
I'm 25 years old.
I've lived like hopefully a quarter of my life.
Right.
(man chuckling)
So yeah man, I'm getting outta the bathtub
and it's so much pain,
elbows hurting, tendonitis really bad.
We're watching the documentary "Forks Over Knives"
and the doc goes on and he goes,
"The cause of inflammation in tendonitis people,
all these people are suffering from tendonitis is milk."
And I was like,
(man chuckling)
milk, and meat, and dairy is causing all this,
it causes inflammation in the joints.
And then I was like, wow, is it really that simple?
Like, is that the reason why I was?
I need to lay off the meat.
And we kept watching the documentaries.
Not "Cowspiracy" wasn't out yet.
"Frankensteer," and where the meat was coming from,
and we were seeing,
I was seeing how they spray all the cattle with pesticides
and 80% to keep the flies off of 'em.
And you know, all that crap that's in the pesticides.
And 80% of antibiotics that are supposed to go to humans
go to animals.
Like all the ones that FDA or whoever didn't clear,
they go to the animals
and they feed 'em
'cause they're walking around their own shit.
And they eat their own shit,
and they cannibalize the cows
and feed 'em cow blood from the other cows that died,
and other cows that died of just natural,
not natural sickness, but sickness.
They feed 'em those cows.
So I was like, man,
it makes sense why I'm not at the top of my game right now.
Why my tendonitis is coming on like it is,
or you know?
So after that I went vegan,
and literally like.
That's amazing though
'cause I would think that at that moment
you're also thinking,
yeah, but I can't do,
I'm in the NFL, man.
Yeah.
I can't,
like, I hear that,
but if I go vegan,
I'm gonna lose all my muscle.
How am I gonna ever stay strong?
How am I gonna keep the weight?
You're having trouble keeping the weight on as it was.
As it was.
And I was like, well first of all-
That's a pretty terrifying prospect,
or pretty ballsy.
Yeah.
It was.
I was scared.
I was scared, I was really scared.
But I was like,
(men laughing)
you know what?
I was like, man, forget it.
You know, after right now it's like this,
it's like, I can go vegan,
or I can just suffer and like have tendonitis,
and probably die at,
the average death of a football player is 56 years old
and most people don't know that.
And that's from eating all that crap and taking-
That heart disease?
I mean, most heart disease, right?
Heart disease and stroke.
A lot of guys, stroke.
And so I was like, you know what?
Forget it.
I'd rather have quality of life
than keep playing,
than hopefully keep playing
and then, you know?
Right.
Just be all in bad shape.
Yeah.
You gotta be careful who you mention that to though
'cause they're gonna think
actually you got, you have like a TBI,
like traumatic brain injury.
Oh no.
(man laughing)
Considering going vegan.
No, man.
Something's wrong with this guy's head.
I got big balls.
That's what that is.
(men laughing)
But, but you know,
so I did a lot of research
and looked up a couple of bodybuilders,
vegan body builders.
I was like, that's the best place to start.
And I saw that the strongest man in the world,
or one of the strongest men in the world,
he's a vegan guy outta Germany.
Yeah, Patrick.
Patrick Baboumian.
Yeah.
He's a friend of mine.
The guy's awesome.
Have you met him yet?
No, I want to.
Oh, you gotta meet him.
He's dope.
I want to,
I wanna fly out to Germany and see him.
Get some tips from him.
I was on stage with him in Toronto
at the Veg Fest a couple years ago
when he did that world record setting lift,
1200 pounds for 10 meters.
I saw that.
I made
a little video of it.
Yeah, he was super cool.
Yeah.
The Human Wolverine.
Yeah, he looks like him.
(men laughing)
Yeah.
But yeah, he was one of the guys I saw,
and I was like, man,
all right, well, he's not 300 pounds.
He was like 265 at the time.
Yeah, he's half your height.
Yeah.
And I was like, shit, if he's the strongest man,
one of the strongest men in the world,
I can do it.
So I did more research,
and then I was like,
'cause at the time I was like,
man, well where am I gonna get my protein from?
I need protein.
I was one of those guys.
And then I was like.
Well that just means you're pretty much everybody.
Basically.
Yeah.
(men chuckling)
But I started doing the research
and I went on to Plant Built.
There's a bunch of bodybuilders,
of plant-based bodybuilders and they were cool guys.
And I reached out to Guacamo and his and his wife
and they helped me out.
They sent me like a-
Marchesi.
Yeah.
Guacamo Marchesi.
Marcheese.
I can't never say
his name right.
I don't know.
But, but they sent me,
they helped me out,
and they sent me some tips,
and kind of took it from there.
They sent me tips
and I took it from there,
and I started doing more research
and learned all the plant-based proteins,
and what are the highest forms of protein,
and where I can get 'em.
And then I just started from there,
and kind of turned into like a plant-based scientist
and started testing out some of
how I can gain weight
and where I can get the most energy
from all the plant-based foods and all that stuff.
All right, and so in the timeline,
this is in the off season?
Yeah.
When you're playing for the Raiders?
No, this Cowboys.
This is when I was,
yeah, this is when I got released from the Cowboys.
Okay.
In the off season
And then, so I meet this,
I have this trainer while I'm in Dallas.
I'm training for the next season,
and he's not vegan at all.
Hispanic guy named Moses Castro out out of Dallas, Texas,
and great trainer.
And he wasn't vegan,
and I told him I was like,
"Hey man, I'm going vegan."
And he said, "Wait a minute, what?"
(men laughing)
"What are you doing, bro?
You're gonna lose all of your weight.
You're gonna not be strong anymore.
Where are you gonna get your protein from?"
And I was like, "Man, just go with me on this one."
We're gonna see what happens, right?
So, we did it.
I went vegan,
and then I ended up losing weight,
but I was getting stronger.
My arms started healing up.
My tendonitis just started disappearing overnight.
I was like, oh my gosh.
I was able to do all kind of pushups
and I was doing hundreds of pushups.
My bench press went up to, from like,
I was able to,
before when I was hurting the tendonitis,
I can only bench press like 315 for like four or five,
which is not a lot for me.
Right.
But when I went vegan, I lost weight
but my bench press went up,
I lost 40 pounds in my weight
and my bench press went up to like 425.
And then it went up to 435 and 465 eventually.
Wow.
Yeah, so initially you went down to about,
you probably went down to about 260?
255?
265.
Yeah.
Back down.
Did you have a little moment of panic?
Yeah.
Yeah, I freaked out a little bit,
but then I started,
had to get back in the books
and do some more research and try to figure out how to,
I had to boost my calories.
I talked to Guaco again.
I had to boost my calories,
and I had to do 10,000 calories a day.
Never in my life,
never had to eat 10,000 calories a day.
And not on a vegan diet.
That's the hardest thing in the world.
That's a lot more food.
Yeah.
And your trainer, when you lost all that weight,
was he trying to talk you out of it?
No, he was,
I told him, I said, "Look man, I'm doing it."
I'm feeling hell out healthier.
He was seeing the,
and he wasn't trying to change my mind
'cause he was seeing the improvements.
As a matter of fact, he went vegan.
Oh, wow.
Yeah, he went vegan.
He was like, he came back one day,
he was like, "I see all the improvements that you're making
and I'm decided I'm going vegan now."
That's amazing.
(man chuckling)
Yeah.
And he's now, he's running like crazy.
He's doing marathons and stuff.
He's doing very well for himself.
That's cool.
All right, so you drop the weight
and it's sort of like, you gotta strip it all down
and build it back up again.
Right?
And as you're starting to slowly put weight back on,
the bench press numbers are going up,
the squat numbers are going up,
the tendonitis is going away,
the arthritis is going away.
How about the nerve damage in the arm?
Nerve damage gone.
The grip in my hands is doing really,
is gone.
I was able to do more than I've ever done before.
I was stronger.
I felt like a Superman.
I was stronger than I've ever been,
even when I was my healthiest in college.
So it is perfect, man.
It just went away.
The only thing I could say was vegan diet.
I know it sounded like a vegan spokesman.
I kind of am.
Well, you are.
Yeah.
Yeah, I really am.
Well, what's interesting about that
is that a lot of people say,
especially with strong man,
and bodybuilders,
and kind of power lifter type guys that go plant based,
people will say,
"Yeah, well he was already big,"
so he's just using the strength that he already,
he already had all that mass.
He put all that mass on
when he was eating the way he was eating before,
so it doesn't really count.
Yeah.
But with you
losing the weight
and then bringing it back up again, injury free.
Yeah.
That's
a different story.
And a lot sexier than I was before.
Yeah, way sexier.
Not gonna lie.
I mean, whoa
(man laughing)
whoa, whoa.
Paige, is he sexier now?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, man.
But yeah, it is awesome, man.
Way less body fat,
way more, a lot quicker than I was before, you know?
Right, so you put the weight back on,
but the lower body fat,
so it's actually,
you probably added more muscle mass than you had before.
Definitely.
I kind of have a six pack now.
Well, for 310 pounds
I'm looking really good.
I'm 310 right now.
All right, well we'll get a picture of that.
Put it on the website.
For sure.
For everybody to see.
Right on.
So, meanwhile,
you're waiting for the phone to ring, right?
Yeah, and then the Raiders call,
and I go,
I end up going to the Raiders.
We trained for that.
I ended up going for the Raiders.
I got my weight up to like 290,
wasn't exactly 300,
but I got my weight up to 290.
And hold on a second.
So what's the average weight of a defensive lineman,
or somebody in your position?
I mean, is it 300?
330 plus.
Yeah, so that's kind of like the bottom threshold?
Yeah, that's like the kind of the cutoff point.
You're going try for a team,
for you to playing D line,
you need to be three plus.
Yeah, so unless you're playing defensive end
where they're smaller.
Right, right.
Yeah,
but I had signed with the Raiders,
and then I went over there running,
I was like, it was impressive.
I was running with the defensive backs
and the wide receivers,
and it was like, they would be tired.
And I'm like, "Are y'all tired?"
I'm just gonna go work out some more.
I had mad energy just from eating.
I was eating good,
and doing my vegan supplements,
and all that stuff and never got tired.
Right.
And yeah, I think I read you were throwing down
seven minute miles.
Yeah, seven minute miles at 290.
Right.
Yeah.
It was impressive.
It's very impressive actually,
but yeah.
And so are you,
and you're open about the way that you're eating, right?
So what are the other players saying?
What's the coach saying?
What are the team trainers saying?
Yeah, well, you know, the team trainers,
they were like,
"Where are you getting your protein from?"
And I'm like, I laughed.
I didn't mean to laugh, but I laughed.
You can get protein anywhere, man.
It's all in this, that, and the other.
You know, showing them like, it's in the peas.
There's more protein in a handful of peas
than there is in a steak,
in an eight ounce steak.
And they're like, "Oh, okay."
And they started seeing me lifting the weights
and lifting with the big guys,
and lifting with the heaviest guys,
and running with the smallest guys.
And they were over there timing me,
and I caught 'em timing me one time.
They were like,
(man imitating snapping)
and then I would go back around and run another lap
'cause we were running laps,
and then they were like,
"And how heavy is he?"
(men laughing)
And I'm running with the smaller guys.
And at the end of the run,
the smaller DBS would be bending down and gasping for air.
And I would go and just jog,
and then go stretch out real quick,
and then go lift weights again.
So that was my first time being vegan
and coming back into being on the team.
So it was really good to,
that was a great feeling to have and to-
And so are they just scratching their heads
going how's this possible?
Or are they thinking, oh, you must be doing something else?
It can't be the vegan diet.
Yeah.
It's so different
than anything they've ever been exposed to.
It must have been confusing for them.
It's a little scary for them
because it challenges their way of life,
their whole way of life.
'Cause you know, every dude's like, I'm a meat eater.
You know, being a football player,
that's the big, manly, macho thing
is eat steak, eat red meat,
protein shake.
Ugh.
But I'm doing it a totally different way
where I'm doing it on plant based,
all that stuff,
and it challenges everything.
It's to the point where football teams
are sponsored by Muscle Milk,
and hot wing companies,
and McDonald's and all that stuff.
So yeah, it's a challenge.
It's challenges their way of life
and they're baffled by it
'cause it's something they never seen before.
Right,
but in this case you're strong,
you're injury free,
you're killing it in training camp.
Everyone's taking notice.
Like, where does this,
how does this play out for you?
I mean, where does this go?
So like you said, everything's going good,
but I just feel like the team didn't take so kindly to it.
'Cause you know, me being vegan,
like I said, it's different,
and it's,
a lot of people aren't used to that.
Say a week later,
this next Monday, I was gone.
The team cut me.
So, you know, it's a new thing
for being in my position,
being 300 pounds and totally obliterating the idea
that you can be big and strong and not eat meat.
It is different for teams.
Yeah.
And a lot of guys were trying to,
were were looking into going vegan
'cause they weren't feeling too healthy.
They weren't feeling, the big guys,
they weren't feeling,
they had back problems and stuff.
And I don't think they wanted that influence on the team.
You know, the,
you should probably stop eating so much meat.
You should, you know.
The influence that resolved your arthritis
and your tendonitis.
Yeah.
That wouldn't be good.
No, no.
No getting healthy.
Listen man,
you know, that's the kind of unfortunate price
that somebody in your position
who's trying to break a paradigm has to face
in order to kind of break the chain
and open the door for the next wave of people
to come through.
Somebody's gotta be first.
Yeah.
And sometimes the guy who's first
becomes the casualty.
Yeah.
But it's fun being the underdog,
and it's fun,
it's interesting being the guy who does it first,
like you said, you know?
There's a couple guys in the NFL now, I think.
Oh, yeah.
Griff Whalen.
Yeah,
he's a cool guy.
Stanford.
Yeah.
(men laughing)
But him, Tony Gonzalez.
Yeah, that's right.
Is he still vegan?
I don't think he's vegan anymore.
I think he's back on chicken and other stuff.
I don't know.
Don't quote me on that.
But he did vegan for a while,
and you know, that's big time
to show that you can do it vegan.
He was a tight end, a smaller guy,
but he still did it, man.
And he, you know, one of the greatest.
Yeah, and Aaron Foster for a while,
but I think he's not on it.
Yeah, he's not on it anymore.
But he still did very well while he was on it too.
Yeah, he seems like a cool dude though.
Yeah, he's cool.
All right, so you get cut
and it's back to the drawing board.
I mean, how do you pick up the pieces from that?
Well, I just concentrated on my diet
because it was still in the beginning stages of me,
not diet, lifestyle.
It was still in the beginning stages of me being vegan.
So I was still experimenting on
how to get the best fuel.
You know how that goes.
What to eat,
how am I gonna gain all this weight?
How the hell am I gonna get to 10,000 calories,
300 grams of protein a day,
300 plus grams of protein a day?
So that was a constant task in itself.
So I did that,
and I continued training,
and I started working with my coach, John Blake.
He's a coach outta Dallas.
He coached a lot of Hall of Famers
in the defensive line position.
And we created video tapes,
send it out to all the teams,
and ended up getting signed with the Jacksonville Jaguars.
And, you know, I did very well over there.
Put up some good stats in the preseason I was there,
put up some good stats, and then.
This was last year?
This is last season, this past season.
And was doing very well.
Team loved me, coaches loved me.
They were like, "Oh, you're doing great."
And they know about the vegan thing?
They know about it.
They were fine with it.
They were
cool with it.
totally cool with it.
See, some teams are different.
Some teams are totally cool with it.
Like, it's not a big deal.
As a matter of fact, we had another player on the team
who was vegan at that time,
named Ramses Barden.
He's a wide receiver guy.
And, but anyway, so.
That must have been nice to have somebody else
that you could kind of bounce ideas off of.
Yeah, yeah, definitely.
And I was kind of,
were sharing tips back and forth and all that stuff,
but yeah, totally fine with it.
And had a lot of, like I said,
a lot of good stats, a lot of good plays.
One of the scouts came up to me
and was like, "Man, you're doing so well right now.
A lot of the teams are talking about you.
There's a lot of buzz around the league
about you right now."
So I was doing really good,
felt really good about what's going on.
And then, right, the last preseason game,
I was running,
scaling across the line,
trying to make a tackle
on the other side of the line of scrimmage.
I mean on the other side of the line.
And running back was about to cross the goal line.
And I was,
I had my body turned a little bit the wrong way,
and running back went right into my knee,
and I tore my ACL.
I was out for like three months with that right there.
That was pretty much the whole season.
That's it, right?
Yeah.
So I was done for the year off of that.
But, you know, I healed up pretty quickly.
I healed up faster than they thought I would,
but by then the season's full swing.
Right, right.
Yeah, so.
Yeah, so you have yet to have the opportunity
to really show what you're capable of.
Yeah.
That's gotta be sort of exciting,
but also frustrating.
Yeah, it is very exciting,
but it is very frustrating.
But I take it this way,
you know, I have my ups and downs already,
you know, I've,
not already.
I'm sure I'll have more,
but I've done a lot of experimenting
and I feel very comfortable with where I'm at right now
as far as strength goes,
as far as agility goes and health, everything goes.
I figured, I feel like I figured it out
how to be the 300 pound vegan the whole time.
300 pounds plus all the time.
Like I said, right now I'm 310.
Before I was struggling to keep my weight.
Is that the heaviest you've been?
Yeah, that's the heaviest I've been nice ever.
Oh, nice.
(man laughing)
But you know, it's hard to gain the weight
as a vegan,
and that was the really the major part of the struggle.
How am I gonna get this mass?
How am I gonna get this strength up?
Well, not really the strength.
That kind of just came with it,
but the size was the hard part.
Right, so let's talk about that.
Sort of training aspects aside,
what's the typical day in the life of food for you?
Like breakfast, lunch, snacks,
pre-workout, post-workout, dinner.
Okay, so I'm on an interesting food schedule.
It's nothing like yours.
Well, we do different things.
Yeah, totally different.
But I eat on a two,
I have a timer.
Every two hours and my timer goes off.
I'm eating.
Is the timer gonna go off during this podcast?
No, no.
I'm gonna eat.
I got a bowl of blueberries in front of you
and a couple almonds,
but I feel like I should be feeding you more right now.
No, I'm good right now.
All right.
Go get a calorie.
Just let me know if you get hungry.
Yeah.
Thanks, I appreciate it.
But yeah, to reach the 10,000 calories a day,
every two hours I'm eating.
Eating something or drinking a shake.
And it's a lot of preparation.
So in the morning I'll have berries
or some kind of fruit smoothie with a bunch of bananas.
That's another thing.
I'm eating like 25 bananas a day.
Not out here
'cause it's so hard to get organic bananas out here.
In Costa Rica where I train at,
there's free bananas everywhere.
Right.
So organic,
it's the greatest.
Right, right, right.
30 bananas a day program.
Yeah, and that's so many calories and carbs,
which is great for gaining weight.
But yeah, so I do that,
and I do like a bowl of millet
or a bowl of cous cous,
or something like that.
Soaked oats.
I soak a lot of my oats and nuts and stuff
because it helps with digestion
and absorbing as much of the nutrients possible.
That's another thing.
Constantly trying to figure out ways to make food
as dense as possible
and packed with nutrients as possible.
That's where the Vitamix comes in.
Oh, yeah.
'Cause you just
blend it all down and pack so much into it.
Oh, yeah.
If it's greens, or raw vegetables, or fruit,
or whatever,
you can get so much in you so much more quickly.
Yeah, I use the Vitamix like crazy.
I couldn't be vegan without the Vitamix.
Right, right, right.
So tell me what the typical shake,
what's in the typical shake?
Oh, okay.
So the typical shake.
Everybody wants to know that, right?
I know, right?
Like, that's a secret.
I should be selling this.
(man chuckling)
But the typical shake is oats.
What is it?
Wheat germ,
like I said, five bananas.
And this is like one big shake
and I just drink it down.
I'll drink one shake
and then wait 10 minutes and drink another shake.
But I do that.
Five bananas,
coconut cream,
sunflower seeds,
and I just kind of mix it all in there.
And then I get,
I try to get 65 grams of protein
per like 64 ounces container,
and that way I can get,
I just drink it down half.
That's 30 grams of protein.
I drink that before a workout
and I drink the other half after a workout.
And then I just, you know,
I have probably like,
I drink like three of those 64 ounces containers.
Right, right, right.
And in terms of supplements,
just like a plant-based protein supplement?
Like Vega, or Sun Warrior, or something like that?
Well, I use Vega before.
I use a lot of Vega before.
I use their,
but right now, and Health Force.
I use a lot of Health Force,
but right now I don't use much of anything
being out of the country
'cause can't really get anything in.
And that's really when I put on the most of my weight,
the bulk of my weight.
I was using-
That's interesting.
Yeah.
When you stopped
doing the powders?
Yeah, when I stopped doing the powders.
How do you explain that?
Just whole foods, man.
Just dense foods and less processed foods.
I'm not really a huge fan of processed foods.
Right.
I mean, they taste good
and they're a great transition
for people trying to come from the standard American diet
to the vegan diet.
But, you know, there's not a lot of nutrients in them,
but they're still very tasty.
But, yeah.
So when you stopped doing all the powders,
you didn't notice a difference in your ability to recover,
or build mass, or keep weight on,
put weight on?
Yeah.
I stopped using the powders,
and yeah, once again,
I lost a little bit of weight,
but I put the weight back on again.
Not too much weight, like 10 pounds.
So I was like 290,
and I was like, "Oh my gosh, no!
I need to get back up again."
So, but I put on the weight
and I was becoming more cut,
more defined,
stronger.
I was doing 200 pushups a day before.
And then when I started doing more whole foods,
I was doing like, after my 200, okay,
I'm gonna do 300
I'm gonna do 400,
I'm doing like 500 pushups.
Wow.
A day.
It's got a lot easier
'cause I felt like eating the whole foods,
your body can utilize the nutrients more.
When you're eating so many processed foods,
it's hard for your body to break that down.
Your body's confused
and doesn't know really what to do with it.
And it changes your gut biome too.
Yeah, definitely.
So you, you know,
when you're eating all the whole foods,
you're propagating a certain kind of microbiology
in your gut
that acclimates to those kinds of foods, right?
So you're maximizing that by only eating those.
Yeah, definitely.
And then, and that's another thing,
speaking of gut bio,
when I went out to Costa Rica,
I got the privilege of meeting Victorious Kopinskisk.
And he's, you know who that is?
Oh yeah, he's awesome.
John Joseph's always talking about that guy.
Yeah, he's amazing.
He's full of knowledge.
But anyway,
that's the guy who got me doing 200 pushups a day.
And there at 500 pushups.
He was doing 200 pushups a day.
He's 72 years old, I think.
Maybe.
I think he's older than that.
But he's got scoliosis, he's blind,
and he's doing 200 pushups a day.
And I was like,
and he was like, "Oh yeah, David,
I'm doing 200 pushups a day."
I was like, "Are you serious?"
He was like, "I challenge you."
I said, "Okay!"
I was like,
(man chuckling)
I cannot let this 72 year old guy beat me
in a push up competition.
Right.
So now I had to double it
and add an extra a hundred on there.
But anyways.
Wow.
Back to the gut bio,
or, you know, the gut science.
I learned from him how to make probiotics.
And so I've been making my own probiotics
and sauerkraut and that stuff,
and wealth of knowledge.
And it's amazing how if you have the right probiotics,
you taking them like you're supposed to be,
you utilize all the food like you're supposed to be,
your body can digest them.
Right.
More regular.
And those nutrients
become more bio available to you.
Definitely.
Instead of
just passing right through you.
Exactly.
You have so much more energy.
Skin clears up.
My muscle definition clears up.
I mean, clears up.
Definition came about a lot better.
I got bigger.
I felt myself,
I started weighing myself.
I was putting on like five pounds every two weeks.
And it was solid.
I wasn't putting on any fat,
so it was really good.
Right, and what about recovery?
And recovery, it was great.
So one of my workouts is,
when I'm in Costa Rica,
I take a bag,
a big, huge, burlap bag.
I dunno how big it is.
And I fill it up with rocks,
and so what I do is I take this bag,
and I do, I carry it front of my body like this.
I carry it like a person,
and I just carry it up the hill.
And I do that all day and I'll never get tired.
And it's amazing.
I run all day.
Like the stuff that that used to make me tired before
when I was doing a lot of the processed foods and stuff,
you know, it doesn't tire me out anymore.
The oxygen is just free flowing in my body.
I utilize oxygen a lot better.
Recovery time,
I don't get sore after workouts at all anymore.
I see a lot of people post on Instagram,
like about how, "Oh yeah, on leg day.
If it was leg day and the zombie attack happened,
you know, I'm done."
Right.
(man chuckling)
But my legs never get tired.
And my legs are, I lift a lot.
What's the squat and the leg press these days?
(man chuckling)
The squat,
I'm squatting,
just the other day,
yesterday or maybe before,
I squat leg press 1600 pounds, 10 times.
It's working out.
It's working.
You know, 1600 pounds, you know.
(men laughing)
All right.
But yeah, but squat is like 600.
So, I'm doing really well.
Some of the highest numbers I've ever had.
So I'm really impressed
with what I'm able to to churn out on this vegan lifestyle.
Right.
All right, well back to the food timeline.
So we're through breakfast right now.
Okay.
So how does it work?
Snacks, lunch, pre-workout,
afternoon workout,
after workout dinner.
Okay, so snack.
Okay, pre-workout,
I get my workout, pre-workout.
I do maca powder,
and a mix of maca powder, spirulina,
and moringa.
Moringa, that's like the super food,
super fruit of all super fruits.
It's like a plays every position.
Yeah.
It's awesome, awesome stuff.
And it seems to give me a great energy boost before workouts
and it keeps me going.
And 'cause it also has protein in it too.
Right.
But it keeps me going,
keeps me going for the whole workout.
Lots of energy.
And so that's my pre-workout.
And then during the workout
I actually put spirulina in my water.
That's like my little secret.
I take put water in the Vitamix,
put some spirulina in there,
maybe a little bit of moringa,
and I blend it up and it tastes like crap.
But it does great 'cause you're fueling your body.
You're working so hard in the gym,
or at least me.
I work so hard in the gym.
My body needs some fuel,
some nutrients to kind of supplement while working out.
And it does a great job.
It just gives my body that protein right now
that it needs during the workout.
Spirulina is the highest protein content by weight
of any food on the planet.
Yeah, 60% protein.
And I do that in the morning too,
but I'll put a little, I'll squeeze some lemon in it
to make it,
it actually tastes a lot better if you do that.
But it's incredible how you just immediately feel good.
Yeah.
It's just water,
spirulina, and a little lemon,
and you're like, boom, zinger.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
I never talked to anybody else
that did that though,
so I thought I was the only guy doing that.
'Cause for most people it's unpalatable.
Yeah.
It's not like it tastes good.
No, no.
I'm gonna have to try the lemon thing.
Yeah, it does taste like ass.
Sorry for all the curse friends, but yeah.
That's all right, man.
It's a podcast, dude.
Oh.
Say whatever you want.
All right.
Cool, cool.
All right, so that's like during workout,
and then I assume like after workout, another shake?
Yeah.
Is that what you do?
So after workout,
I take another shake down,
probably like 500 calories
'cause I'm lifting heavy weights,
and I'm trying to gain weight.
I don't wanna just take a shake down
that's gonna be just enough to refuel my body.
So I mean just enough to barely meet my muscle mass
and all that stuff,
so I'm drinking at least 30,
not at least 30 grams,
'cause your body can only process 30 grams of protein
after you work out, or 25 grams of protein,
so I do like 30 grams shaker protein.
And then I do 500 calories of,
it's a combination of bananas, oatmeal, wheat germ.
Like I said, I put some flaxseed in there.
Also do flaxseed before workouts
because that actually helps your body to burn fat,
your fat energy stores for energy during the workout,
prolonging your workout,
making it,
which I have great workouts when I use flaxseed.
And it also lowers your blood pressure
for guys who have high blood pressure problems.
And I used to have high blood pressure,
so I'm always taking it, but.
Right.
Is the blood pressure good now?
Oh yeah, blood pressure's fine.
I don't have any problems with it,
but yeah, after workout,
so bananas, flaxseed,
oats,
so I do soaked oats,
because that,
they're pretty much more digestible that way,
and yeah.
What about beans and legumes?
That's more like a dinner thing?
I put beans in there sometimes.
A lot of times.
In your blend?
Yeah.
Oh, you blend them up in your drink?
It's protein.
Really?
I've never done that.
How does that taste?
Well, I put black beans in there sometimes.
It is not very pretty.
Right.
But usually do
white beans or something like that.
And then, you know, at least it looks nice,
but it's the same amount of protein,
and it's got a lot of calories, a lot of fiber in it,
and that's another good thing too.
Fiber is good for muscle development.
A lot of people don't know that they have fiber deficiencies
and that's why they're not building muscles.
They think it's protein,
but it's really you don't have enough fiber in your system.
But yeah, so I do that.
That's beans, bananas,
flax, oats, and wheat germ.
What about, you ever do beets?
I do beets before workout.
Pre workout.
Yeah, yeah.
Pre workout, yeah.
Man.
Dude.
It's like, that's crazy how much better you feel.
You feel like you just,
every breath you take in is like three breaths.
Yeah, definitely.
I learned that from Paul Shapiro,
who's a good friend of mine.
Oh, at Humane Society?
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Good friend of mine.
I owe him a workout,
and he's like, "Oh, I workout with you."
I don't know if you can hang bro,
but okay.
(man laughing)
We went to the same high school.
Really?
Yeah, yeah.
Small world.
I mean, I'm way older than him,
but I know Paul.
Oh, yeah.
He's cool.
Him and his brother.
I call his brother,
like the vegan Rambo.
That guy's got case out against the FBI and all kind of.
Right.
Yeah, it's a hardcore situation.
Yeah.
I met his dad.
He grew up in a really conservative family,
but when he was, when he was in high school,
he had crazy dreadlocks and you know,
like growing up in DC like that,
that's radical.
You know, he was always an activist dude.
Yeah.
They're cool.
I like him, man.
They're great people.
What were we talking about?
We're talking about dinner.
Dinner.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
We weren't but we are now.
We are now.
Yeah, that's where we're heading.
Yeah.
But dinner,
one of my favorite things is Gallo Pinto,
which is beans and rice.
It's beans and rice.
Comprised of a complete protein.
Most people don't know that.
And it's very filling.
Plenty of carbs, plenty of calories,
plenty of fiber,
plenty of protein.
And I usually add avocado, tomato,
and some queso on there.
I make that in the Vitamix with the nutritional yeast,
which is a complete protein.
Also has B12 in it too.
Plenty of B12 for recovery and all that stuff,
and the cashews.
There's so many calories.
It's like it helps you to,
I feel like that helps to put on so much weight
with the nutritional yeast and the cashews
and all that stuff.
We make cashew cheese and a Vitamix
with nutritional yeast and cashews.
Yeah.
You done that?
Oh, I do it all the time.
That's my favorite.
I do it like every day.
I know.
Like, who am I talking to?
Exactly.
You know
what's funny about,
I mean, I could eat beans and rice every single day.
I pretty much do.
You know, I'm pretty simple.
I like it.
I could have that for dinner every night.
Just that with like a little avocado and some hot sauce,
and I'm good.
Yeah.
And when people say,
"Oh man, you know, plant-based so complicated,
so expensive."
It's like?
It's so simple.
Buy a huge bag of rice,
and a huge bag of beans,
and you're out like 10 bucks,
and you can eat for like a month.
Exactly.
That's the thing.
It takes 10 minutes to make.
Yeah.
Like, expensive?
That's the poor man's diet.
I eat fruit during the day
and I'll eat that for lunch and dinner.
I, honestly, I could like be happy with that.
Yeah, yeah.
As long I have a Vitamix too.
Yeah.
I mean, you can make anything a Vitamix,
but oh, sometimes I make like bean soups.
Just pour bunch of beans in there,
like white beans
and then put a bunch of seasonings in it,
some pumpkin or whatever.
And then it's protein packed, yam,
protein, beans, and yams.
And that's like,
it's sweet.
You put some vanilla in there,
you don't even taste the beans,
but you have the yam in there.
It's super sweet.
It's like a Thanksgiving treat or something like that.
It's awesome.
It takes like no time to make.
No time, but it's full of nutrients.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
All right.
So I got a pretty clear,
what about desserts?
I'm not a real dessert guy.
I don't do desserts.
Oh, banana and ice cream.
Fruit.
Yeah.
That's my fruit.
Or banana and ice cream.
That's like,
I feel like I'm eating ice cream, but I'm not.
But it's just banana.
It's just awesome.
That's good.
So, all right, I get it.
And I want to get into the whole Costa Rica thing,
'cause you kind of went down there with one idea
of what was gonna be up,
and it seems like it's turned into a different thing, man.
Like, suddenly you're living down there.
Yeah, well, we're not living down there.
What's happening?
We're living down there, kind of,
but we're gonna live down there permanently
after everything's all said and done.
But right now, we went out there
to go with with our friend, Tim.
And he's a great guy, animal activist.
He works with Health Force.
He's cool.
He's got this huge, vegan tattoo across his neck.
Oh wow.
Yeah, he's about that life.
But went out there to go visit him,
and work with,
he has this thing called Project Awea,
and it's a turtle farm and they save turtles.
'Cause most turtles,
there are 10,000 turtles born and one of 'em will survive,
so they're going extinct.
So he does that, he saves turtles.
But while we were out there,
we met this girl named Alice,
Ally,
and she's awesome, great friend of ours.
But she would go to this school called Feuturo Verde,
and it's a pretty forward thinking school in Costa Rica,
but it's a private school,
an IB school,
and a baccalaureate school.
So they're doing very well.
But they asked me to do a speech there
and talk to them about veganism and what it entails.
And I went there and I spoke to the kids,
like the little baby kids,
and that was the most frustrating thing I've ever done.
It's so hard to speak to the little kids,
like first, second grade.
It's hard to connect.
Yeah.
Especially
about nutrition.
They like-
"What's calcium?"
Yeah.
You gotta find a way,
you gotta find a way in with kids.
Yeah.
_ [Rich] Right?
It's not easy.
Yeah, definitely.
But then I spoke to the high school kids,
the upper grades,
and after that,
and I told 'em about everything,
how natural flavors, what they're really made of.
Did you know that the natural flavors,
like one of the major ingredients in natural flavor
they derived from beaver butt?
I had heard that,
I mean, the word natural means nothing.
Yeah.
It means absolutely nothing.
It basically means
it's in the three dimensional world.
Pretty much.
(man chuckling)
Yeah.
But yeah, so I talked to them about that,
talked to 'em about how I became vegan,
and you know, the things that I eat and all that stuff,
and how they can start transitioning onto the vegan diet,
and how I'd be good for them,
and how it's cheaper to eat at a vegan diet as well.
That was one of the things that I pitched to 'em.
The next thing I know,
the school is like, "Oh yeah, we wanna start,
we're impressed by your presentation.
We wanna start implementing
vegan into our meal plans at the school."
And started with one day,
we pitched and then like Meatless Mondays,
which was a program that they do out here in the States
is Meatless Mondays and works pretty well.
But we went, talked to 'em,
we told 'em how they're gonna save money doing this.
We're saving money having vegan meal plan,
and how it's gonna be better for the students,
and all that stuff.
They're doing three days a week now
vegan menu.
Wow.
And that's pretty good seeing that.
Actually that's the first school in Costa Rica
to become vegan.
Wow.
But Costa Rica is a pretty interesting place.
I mean, you know, it's incredibly progressive.
They have no army, right?
They have no sort of military set up,
and you know, they're on the cutting edge
of organic farming.
I mean, it's basically an incredibly vegan,
plant-based, friendly place to live.
Might be the most on the whole planet.
Yeah.
The way they function.
It's pretty vegan,
but at the same time,
they're big agriculture people.
They're all about,
like where we are is Montezuma, Costa Rica,
in the Nicoya Peninsula.
One of the Blue Zones.
Yeah, one of the blue zones.
But it's really,
like you said, there's a lot of vegan people out there,
but it's not,
like you said, there's organic farming,
and there's a few vegan people out there,
but it's really grass fed cows and all that.
That's what they're big on right now.
As well as sustainable agriculture.
Yeah, sustainable agriculture.
But that's what they're make their livelihood on,
is selling meat,
and selling cows,
and then very religious out there,
and veganism comes across as a religion.
Being vegan comes across as a religion
to them out there.
And they're like, "Oh no!"
But to have that in one,
in any of the schools in Costa Rica,
or in Latin America is pretty impressive.
And Humane Society International is involved in it now
and they're helping to revamp their menu,
and eventually the school's gonna go completely vegan
all five days.
Wow.
Vegan.
Which is very impressive.
And I'm really thankful for that.
And that's awesome.
That's pretty cool.
That's just like Muse,
Susie Cameron,
Susie Amos Cameron
and her sister Rebecca.
Susie's the wife of James Cameron,
the film director,
and their school Muse
is right on the other side of that hill.
Really?
It's pretty cool.
You should go,
and they have a thing called Muse Talks
that's kind of like a,
they do like a TED Talks thing
where they bring speakers in to speak.
You you would be great.
You should go and give a talk there.
I think I might try and hit 'em up.
Oh, you should.
I'll introduce you.
I did it.
Rick Pestelten's done it.
Neil Barnard's been there.
They just had Sir Ken Robinson.
They get some pretty cool people,
but you would be great.
And they're gonna,
they're instituting the first
all plant-based lunch of any school in the country.
It starts next year.
I mean, they already eat,
they have plant-based every day,
but they have some other options
'cause they just felt like they had to for the parents.
But next year it's full plant based.
They're growing all this food there.
It's an amazing place.
I'm sure you sent your kids to that school.
Well we've been,
we've homeschooled all our kids.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
But our two youngest,
our two little girls,
they were kind of at a point
where it was becoming apparent
that they could benefit from a little bit more structure,
and there were certain things that they wanted to explore,
and they seemed to have an interest in checking it out.
And we've known Susie for a while,
and we're kind of connected to that school,
so it just made sense.
So literally just like three or four weeks ago
they went there to just kind of go
for the end of this year
and see how they liked it.
But they're enjoying it.
I mean, it's amazing.
It's solar powered
and like all this kind of stuff is like,
doesn't exist in any other school.
Yeah.
It's pretty cool.
But I'll make sure that I introduce you to them
'cause you would be cool.
You would be great.
Appreciate it.
But that means
that you can't just go hide out
in Costa Rica all the time, right?
No, we're coming back out here, man.
That's temporary.
We're just setting up for the future.
But you went down there
to go visit some friends,
and did you just stay,
or did you come back?
Have you been kind of going back and forth?
Well, we're coming back and forth,
but we stayed out there for a pretty long time.
It's so amazing.
But, you know, we can't get any work done in Costa Rica.
They don't even have really internet.
(man chuckling)
So we're coming back out here,
and to LA, this is our hometown,
and we're coming back out here,
get some work done.
You know, 300 Pound Vegan is growing
and we're trying to do some things.
Literally and figuratively.
Yeah, definitely.
Right?
Right.
Yeah.
(man chuckling)
But you just need that phone to ring.
Yeah.
How's it looking?
I mean, do you have any,
do you kind of have a sense of how it might play out
right now?
Yeah, it's looking good.
Like I said, before I got hurt,
I was doing very well,
and I had a lot of,
put up a lot of stats,
and, you know, I was impressed with myself.
I'm, oh man, I'm doing this on vegan diet.
This is great.
But actually, I was doing better than I was
when I first came in at anytime in my career.
So, you know, it's just,
right now it's just a waiting game.
So we'll see what happens in August
when the camp starts.
Right, and most guys in your position
would be working with a trainer every day at a gym,
doing that kind of traditional route.
But you're down in Costa Rica,
doing this kind of primal, functional body strength,
swinging from trees,
and carrying rocks around and stuff,
and doing pushups on the beach
with the 72 year old guy.
Right.
So how does that work
when you don't have that kind of familiar accountability
to another person,
and it's kind of all on you to get up in the morning,
and figure out what you're gonna do
to take care of yourself
and put you in a position where when you get that call,
you're ready to show up and play?
It's a challenge.
It makes you,
you have to be accountable to yourself.
I don't have an accountability partner.
I have to get up in the morning,
and get out there before it gets too hot,
and work out by myself.
And before I left,
I sat down with my trainer and my defensive line coach,
who, my pastor's coach who I work with,
and I worked out a workout plan with the two of them.
And you know, I had,
I got that down before I went out there,
but then I started adding my own stuff.
But it,
when you're out there by yourself,
and you're working out like that by yourself,
and doing it all by yourself, you have to push yourself.
It's a mental thing.
And you know, when you're running,
and you're running a hundred miles,
you have to push yourself,
and no one's gonna do it for you.
And I was kind of like a crutch that you had
when you were working with the trainer in-
One you started to slack,
somebody'd be on your back.
Yeah, but when you're doing it,
you gotta push that weight off your chest by yourself.
You know, you gotta carry that weight the rest of the way.
When I'm carrying that huge bag of rocks,
or pulling that tree down the beach,
I have to do it myself.
I have to motivate myself to do it.
And you know, it's physical training,
but it's also mental training as well.
Yeah, it's awesome.
Well, let's get into that part.
I know that yoga and meditation
is kind of a thing that you've gotten into, right?
So how did that start,
and how has that kind of impacted your perspective?
Oh, yoga is awesome.
I think it's,
it clears the mind.
It fixes the body.
It creates space within the body.
And I sound like a yogi.
I'm not.
Yeah, dude.
(man chuckling)
Let's just, straight up,
you're unlike any other football player I've ever met.
Thank you.
I appreciate that.
No, I mean,
that's a good thing, you know?
But it's not normal for an NFL guy
to start waxing poetic about like yoga and meditation.
Man.
It should be.
Yeah, it should, right?
It's like, nutrition should be a very huge thing in sports,
and nutrition, but we already discussed that.
But it's not.
But yoga, man, it's awesome.
It creates space.
You get to you know your body.
You're like having a conversation with your body
when you're doing yoga,
and you get to go into those deep places like my shoulder,
for example, my shoulder injury.
Doing all those downward dog stances,
and doing all those poses,
and stretching, and planting my hands into the ground.
That stuff opens up your,
that stuff, it makes you use those muscles
that you've never used before.
Being a big man,
it's hard to get into those poses,
and crane poses and stuff at 310 pounds.
But it really,
and that's another mental strength thing
you got going on right there.
It forces you to push yourself to places
you've never been before.
And where did it begin for you,
and what was your entry point into yoga?
My beginning point was,
shoot, when I first got into the league,
Paige made me start doing yoga.
I had a feeling you were gonna that.
Yeah.
And come on, man.
I got the same story.
Wasn't gonna start doing it myself.
No, but, where?
I knew that that's,
I had a feeling of what you were gonna say,
which kind of leads me to the next thing
that I was gonna talk about,
which is the importance of having
a strong, supportive partner
who's pushing you to grow and expand,
because, dude, I mean, left to my own devices,
I'm a jack in the box.
You know what I mean?
My wife was really,
you know, she wasn't fully plant based,
she wasn't fully vegan,
but she was leading a healthy lifestyle,
and had healed herself of cyst in her neck using ayurveda,
and she was into yoga and meditation,
and reading spiritual texts,
and always kind of like trying to expand her horizons
and grow,
and I just wasn't interested, you know?
It's like it took me,
I had to get to a place where I was in like a lot of pain
in order to start listening.
But having that partner
who's kind of willing to help
and standing in their strength,
in the light has been transformative for me.
Definitely.
And it sounds like
you've got definitely have the same thing.
Yeah.
Definitely taken me to a place
where I never even thought about going.
Look at Paige and Mike
sitting over there all quiet.
All right.
(men chuckling)
She's good, I think.
All right.
But I mean she's,
you know, listen,
she was the entry point into these nutritional shifts,
entry point into yoga.
Everything, yeah.
Same with meditation.
Yeah, same with meditation.
I was like, mind racing.
I'm not trying to sit down.
I'd rather sit down and watch television or something,
or play football games or whatever,
go work out, whatever.
And I'm not gonna sit there and do nothing for 30 minutes
and just breathe like, okay.
(man chuckling)
Right.
And just,
like I said, mind racing.
But it's amazing how you think
that doing a bunch of stuff
is I'm being productive and being productive.
No, you sit down and you're relax,
and you think about,
you don't even think about anything,
but it just, it helps you to grow.
And that's the easiest way to grow is through meditation.
I was talking to one of my old teammates about it.
And he was like, "Man,"
you know, he was like,
'cause I tell him all the time, "Bro, you should meditate.
You should do yoga."
You should, you should.
And I'm trying to make him vegan.
Now he's talking about I'm gonna be vegan,
but now he's like,
"Hey man, you should meditate."
I'm like, "Man, I'm the one that told you that."
(man laughing)
And he's telling,
he's like, "Oh, you should,
yeah, I'm thinking about going vegan.
You know that?"
I'm like, "Man, I'm the one that told you that!"
But it's great, man.
It does a lot of good things for your mind,
for your body, for your soul.
Now I think it even helps you to heal injuries.
The power of the mind to heal.
Power of the mind, yeah.
Yeah.
Now we're getting all New Age.
I know, right?
Right?
How about that?
Namaste.
So how does that look for you?
I mean,
is there a particular type of meditation that you do, or?
You know, no, I haven't gotten all into it
like that.
I just kind of just relax and I just clear my mind.
I sit down in my yoga pose,
and just, I do it.
And it is not just still meditation.
When I'm doing my yoga,
I sit and I meditate,
or you know, meditate anywhere really.
As long as you just sit down, relax, and clear your mind,
and just get rid of all the world stresses that you have,
the day stresses that you have.
Don't think about what you have going on in the future.
Don't think about what's troubling you from the past,
and just, you know, that stuff.
It works.
It's calming.
That's the best thing.
Most people don't get the chance to have that in the day.
Right, and they may think that like,
Oh, well you're in Costa Rica.
I'm stuck on the 405 while you're sitting on the beach.
You know?
But the truth is,
it's just a choice that you make.
Yeah.
You do it
wherever you are.
You create
your own world.
Right.
Yeah.
But it probably is easier in Costa Rica.
It's a lot easier.
(man chuckling)
I'm not gonna deny that.
Yeah.
How do you handle,
well actually, before I get into that,
I wanted to ask you,
'cause it kind of follows on the heels
of the spiritual aspects of the things
that you're kind of stepping into
and growing into,
which is the ethical side of being vegan.
I mean, initially you made the switch
because you were injured
and you wanted a healthier way of,
sort of being a football player.
Yeah.
And now you have
a different perspective,
or maybe I should say a more expanded perspective.
'Cause you know,
you're a pretty passionate, animal rights advocate
and it didn't start out that way.
So I'm interested in how that kind of came about.
Yeah,
well definitely once I went vegan,
initially was like you said, just for health reasons.
But then when I realized
we don't need meat at all to survive,
and I was pushing up big numbers in the gym,
and running well,
and been putting on more weight than I had ever had before.
You realize that
the only real reason to eat animal animals is for greed.
You know?
And I remember you said that it is the middle man.
You're the middle man.
I mean, the animals are the middle man.
We're still the middle man.
Yeah, I mean, I think there's this idea
that we're obligate omnivores,
that we must eat meat,
and so sort of livestock agriculture
is just a necessary thing that we have to do.
But once you realize we're not obligated omnivores.
It's a choice.
Yeah.
And we can not only survive
but actually thrive without them,
it's impossible to not go,
well, if that's the case,
then like, what are we doing?
Yeah, it's an old concept
that we need to eat meat.
You know, like people who assume that we're,
like you said, we're carnivores,
We're not.
Our intestines are not made for it,
or we don't have claws,
we don't have large fangs, you know?
We can't run down a deer and chase 'em down,
you know, none of that stuff.
And so, it's science, man.
We're not made to eat meat at all.
And really the more people find that out,
then the better the world's gonna be.
And I feel that people are just unaware.
And because of that,
animals are dying every day by the billions and everything.
And it's not just food.
It's everything.
It's, for example, soap.
Most people don't know.
They look on,
that soap is made from dogs.
What?
Yeah.
Wait, I didn't know this.
Hold on a second.
Soap.
That can't be true
in the United States.
What do you mean made from dogs?
Made from dogs, bro.
Okay.
Come on.
Soap.
If you look on the back of your soap,
and there's gonna be an ingredient on the back of the soap,
glycerin.
Glycerin basically is just a scientific term for,
okay, this is what they do.
All the dogs that are in the dog pound,
they get put to sleep.
They take 'em and they gotta go somewhere.
They're not burning them up, incinerating them,
or bury them somewhere.
They're taking them.
They take 'em to a factory somewhere.
They boil em and they,
the fat that comes from the dogs
and whatever other animals they put in there,
cats, dogs, whatever,
they just take the fat off,
skim it off the top,
and they make, that's glycerin.
I didn't know that.
They make the soap.
Most people don't know that
every time they wash their hands,
they're putting dead dog fat on their hands.
And it makes you think like,
man, what other things are we utilizing animals for
that they don't need to be utilized for?
Dogs are being put to sleep,
and being caught by the dog pound,
and they're like finding reasons to kill dogs.
You know?
I know it's a lot of them, but damn,
like, you know, you don't gotta kill all of them.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And so, but where does this creep in?
Is this just a natural evolution
of you kind of realizing like,
oh wow, I'm actually doing really well.
Yeah.
Without meat,
and it just naturally led you to question these paradigms,
or?
Yeah.
Is there like a book that you read, or?
This has become the main part
of who you're all about.
Yeah.
What
you're all about.
I read the book "Mad Cowboy,"
read a couple but "Mad Cowboy,"
where that's the,
and "Meat Is For Pussies."
I forget the name of the other book,
but a really good book.
And it talks about all the things that they do
that it just,
totally just not necessary to the animals.
For example, animals that we eat,
that they eat.
Those people.
And that they eat,
that the pain and the suffering that they go through.
And that's totally unnecessary.
And when you, when you take a step back
and you realize that,
wow, like all this is going on
just so I can have a steak?
you know, they're raping cows to have other cows.
Leather seats in my car or whatever.
Yeah, you have, yeah.
Or yeah, that's another thing,
the death march
where they take the cows and they march 'em
all the way.
They can't kill 'em in India
'cause they're honored,
the cows are honored,
so they death march 'em.
They walk across.
Across the boundary line.
Yeah.
Man, that's wild.
And just so they can kill 'em at the end, yeah.
And when you realize that all that stuff
and how unnecessary it is,
especially when we don't need animals to survive
in any capacity.
It's 2015.
We don't need leather seats in our car.
We can make a composite leather out or whatever
and use that,
or not composite, but you know, we can make.
Yeah, there's all kinds.
I mean it's 2015.
There's a million kinds of modern textiles
that we don't really have to use that.
We just like the way it smells.
Exactly.
The way it feels.
We like our steak.
It makes us feel
regal, you know?
That's where they are.
Or masculine.
I mean?
Yeah, masculine.
Masculinity is a big part of this whole thing too,
and that's why I think you're such a powerful example
being a football player,
and being a 300 pound guy,
because men associate their sense of identity
with these sorts of things.
It's like they gotta have their steak
because it's not just it tastes good.
That's part of it.
But, but there's a gender identity that comes with that,
and when you kind of speak to that,
it becomes very threatening or destabilizing.
And it's one thing for like a skinny, ultra runner guy
to talk about it.
It's a very different thing for a guy
who can throw up 400 plus pounds on the bench press
and is playing in the NFL to talk about it.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's the thing that,
it does make a difference.
I was talking to somebody about it yesterday
and they're like,
"Why do most men feel
that they have to be eat meat to be a man?"
And that is, it's true.
That's what a lot of guys think.
90% of the men in the world think that.
They feel like,
I know most guys,
I don't know, like, "I'm a man.
There's only protein in here.
I gotta eat this animal,"
you know, "or get the blood,"
and it's tearing their meat.
Like they're some kind of warrior or something
like that.
Yeah,
some carnivore.
No, that's not the case.
No, you don't have to eat this in innocent animal.
First of all, you couldn't go hunt that animal down
if you wanted to yourself anyway.
Like I said, you don't have the,
unless you, if you took away the gun.
Like going to the Ralph's
and they're getting it in cellophane, or the Whole Foods.
Yeah, you're not hunting.
The whole hunter-gatherer concept is out,
that's out the window.
You're not doing any of that.
You're grocery shopping.
But, so you're not really being,
that's not really manly.
That's opportunist.
Like you're out there, it's convenient
to go get the meat in the store
and you're just feeding whatever,
getting, eating whatever somebody tells you.
I think part of it also is that,
you know, a lot of men feel emasculated
because of the way our society is set up.
You know, you're stuck in a job you hate,
you're sitting in a cubicle.
You're not living the life of a primal man,
so it's one way of saying,
well, at least when I do this,
it makes me feel manly,
even if it's a complete illusion or fallacy.
'Cause it runs deep, man.
It's like a powerful, emotional thing.
Yeah.
And that's why
I think it's so tough for so many dudes
to wrap their head around
the idea of embracing this lifestyle.
It's just, it's super scary and threatening,
because they associate it with undermining their manhood.
Yeah.
And the truth is like,
real manhood,
true masculinity, I think is,
yeah, it's being compassionate.
It's taking care of of those
that can't take care of themselves.
Exactly.
And not only that,
being around to protect your family, you know?
Right.
Yeah.
Like you said, protecting your family.
Let's get on that.
If you die
of a heart attack at 50 and you're not around for,
you know?
You can't protect
your family.
You're not
taking care of them.
Exactly.
And then not only that, bro,
like think about this.
You have your kids,
you have kids.
You know what's in that.
Now if you were to inform yourself
what goes into a steak?
You have all those antibiotics,
you have all those pesticides,
you have all those drugs,
and everything that they pump into the cows,
pigs, whatever.
And you cut that up,
you go buy it in the store,
you cut it up,
you put it on the plate, and you feed it to your child.
You are not protecting your child,
you're harming your child in that sense.
You know your wife,
and that you're not protecting anybody.
You're poisoning them.
You're allowing big agriculture, or whatever,
the big farm companies,
all these companies
to poison your child or your wife.
Yeah, that's a good pint.
Yeah, so that's not being manly at all, man.
That's being,
I'm not trying to be too aggressive here,
but that's being stupid.
Right.
You know?
So what do you,
how do you address it when you,
the guys that you train with,
other football players,
dudes you see in the gym
who are probably rolling up on you.
"Oh, hey man,
Dave Carter playing in the NFL."
Like, you know, "Oh vegan, really?"
Well I'm on a paleo diet.
It's working for me.
Or, you know, what's wrong with paleo?
'Cause it's all about paleo now.
It's like the big craze.
Yeah, always trying to create some confusion.
So yeah, how do you navigate those conversations?
So I tell 'em first,
one of the biggest things that I like to tell 'em
is that like, "Man, that's cool."
You're eating cleaner than,
I don't know, you're eating cleaner than a lot of people,
but bro, do you understand how the human body is designed?
Your human body is not designed to eat meat
in any capacity.
Like, you're intestine.
Well, they'll just
tell you're wrong about that.
Yeah.
Man, it's science.
Look it up.
Google it,
like the internet is right there at your fingertips.
But the internet is full
of all kinds of conflicting,
confusing information.
It's not always like,
the solution to like Google something.
Because for every study you find,
you can find a conflicting study.
Yeah.
Unless
you read the whole thing
and figure out who paid for it,
and you have a background in science
where you can understand whatever bias is built in
to whatever study on either side of the equation,
then your whole day's over,
and you know what I mean?
You can go down that rabbit hole forever.
It is.
It is a challenge to go against those people who are,
they're just so gung-ho about staying on the paleo diet,
staying eating meat.
They're just, it's like a drug rhythm,
you know,
they're trying to find any reason to stay eating meat.
And what I do is,
I tell 'em about that.
How scientifically humans are not designed to eat meat,
or I read to them the heart disease rates
and stroke rates and what directly correlated
to meat consumption and dairy consumption,
and how the, for example, the milk company,
this was one thing I love to tell.
How they're like,
I always go, "You remember that the commercial
'Got Milk' commercial?"
Of course.
How could you forget?
It's like permanently tattooed on my brain.
Yeah.
I mean,
it would be impossible to not know what that was.
Exactly.
Or, and they're like,
"Milk does a body good," and all that stuff.
Well, legally they can no longer say that
because they cracked down on them
and there's been studies that have been done,
and you're like, well they,
"Oh, milk is good for you. Milk is good for you!"
Well legally, no, it's not.
(man chuckling)
They can no longer say milk does a body good
because it does not.
So they can get sued for that.
So is that why they changed the slogan
from "Milk does the body good" to "Got milk?"
To "Got milk?" and protein,
and milk has protein in it.
And so people,
they don't know about these things
because those things are hidden.
And milk company do a great job of hiding that stuff.
And like you said, the meat companies,
they do a really good job of hiring teams of researchers
to generate false information
and false studies to argue
these Harvard studies that have proven that meat,
it causes heart attacks,
coagulates the arteries and causes heart attack
and stroke and all that stuff.
And you know,
but you just have to,
I like to plant seeds in people's mind
and tell 'em like, just look for yourself, man.
Do the research.
I've done the research,
and one of the things is they,
you can see that you can by looking at me
that you're not gonna get weak and small by being a vegan.
So let that be enough, man.
And do some research,
and watch some documentaries,
and find out for yourself,
and don't just listen to what anybody's just telling you.
Do your own research,
and be your own nutritionist,
and be your own scientist.
'Cause every time you,
eating is one of the things that you do most times a day.
Most people eat three times a day.
What else are you doing three times a day?
Nothing.
People don't shower three times a day.
You know, none of that stuff.
So it is like,
at least be aware of what it is that you're doing
the most time, most of your life.
Don't just allow,
don't just let it be anything
that you're putting down your mouth,
or feeding to your kids,
or feeding to your pregnant wife, whatever.
Yeah, educate yourself.
Yeah.
Invest yourself
in what that's all about
and connect yourself more closely to the food choices
that you're making.
Yeah.
For yourself
and for your kids.
I mean, I think for you,
the most powerful thing that you can do,
and the most powerful way for you to carry the message,
is just to keep getting stronger
and play your ass off on the field.
You know what I mean?
Because especially for dudes,
it's what you do is gonna trump
whatever's coming outta your mouth.
Yeah.
It's almost like
if you do that,
it doesn't matter what you're,
you don't have to say anything.
Yeah.
Because everyone gets it.
So I wanna see you kicking some ass.
Thanks, man.
I'm going to.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Cool.
Well I think that's a beautiful way to wrap it up
and close it down,
but I think,
one thing I'd like to leave people with is
maybe some tips,
or some inspiration for somebody who's listening to this
and they're new to these ideas,
and they're interested, they're intrigued.
They're like, "Wow, I never would've thought
a dude in the NFL.
Like, really?"
And so maybe they're ready
to kind of dip their toe in the water.
Where would you, or where do you suggest
people make that first step?
How do you do that?
Well.
I mean, you're an all-in dude.
I kind of was a little bit too,
you know what I mean?
Yeah, I started.
You flip that switch
and it's over with,
but most people aren't like that.
Yeah, I started like,
like you said, all in the next day.
But it's hard for a lot of people to go vegan.
'Cause first, they don't even know where to begin.
And, you know,
the best way to do is to look up some,
start researching,
and look up some,
you don't really have to look far,
look on the internet and look up some recipes,
and find some creative recipes.
Something easy, something simple
that you can make really quickly,
and you know, it's not a huge hassle.
And that's what I'm doing right now.
I'm working with this company,
it's called Lighter,
and we're creating,
it's Lighter,
and it is a group.
The nutritionist is actually a runner,
a marathon runner,
and we're working together to create Heavier,
which is my half of Lighter.
Wow.
It's pretty cool,
right?
No, it's not Heavier, it's Stronger.
That was the first name.
Stronger.
Yeah, heavier is kind of a negative.
Most people don't want to get.
Yeah, they don't want heavier.
No, it's Stronger.
But it's an awesome concept.
It's really,
it's a personal nutritionist,
and they do all the shopping for you basically,
and bring it to your front door.
It's like an app?
That's what you're talking about?
It's a website,
and it's called Lighter.
Lighterculture.com.
Yeah, it's pretty awesome man.
Great stuff.
And they do the best job to get
as close to non GMO as possible.
They follow, is it called the Big Nines?
Dirty Dozens.
Oh, Dirty Dozens.
Yeah, the Dirty Dozens.
And it's awesome, awesome.
They get great products and all that stuff,
and they have recipes,
and a lot of my recipes are up there.
And what I do to, my weight gaining recipes,
and what I do for pre-workout,
after workout, and all that stuff.
So, it's awesome.
But that's one option.
But then, you know, going online and looking up,
there's another great website,
it's ohsheglows.com.
They have great recipes.
That's one of the websites that got me started,
and it's very easy.
Yeah, yeah.
She's awesome.
That's cool.
But yeah, there's plenty of vegan options.
Like I said, I'm not a big fan of the processed foods,
but there's huge,
there's Gardein and-
Beyond Meat.
Beyond Meat is awesome.
They have great food, Beyond Eggs.
Just Mayo.
I love Just Mayo.
Yeah. I mean,
so for somebody who's not ready to let go of those,
like for you and me,
it's like, I don't,
it's not about that stuff anymore,
but like most people,
they need to transition.
So yeah, those foods are their place for that.
But I think people over complicate it in their mind
because they don't know, right?
So they think it's gonna gonna be hard or-
Cardboard food.
Yeah, or all this meal prep.
They're gonna have to spend all day,
because spend all day in the kitchen creating these recipes
'cause the idea is
oh, you're trying to recreate something
that tastes like meat and dairy,
but it's not about that.
No.
It's so simple.
It's like, look, we're sitting here, we're eating,
we're eating a bowl of blueberries.
Yeah.
Did we have to prepare that?
No, it's already made.
We had a big bag of almonds over there,
and some bananas,
and a big bag of rice ,and a big bag of beans.
And like, if all you did was go to the store
and buy a bag of rice and beans.
You're good.
That's a meal.
That's a huge start.
Yeah.
Make a big thing
of rice and a big thing of beans
and put it in your refrigerator,
and then you can eat for a week.
Yeah, just add some simple things.
Avocado, tomato, and you're good.
And that's a full-on delicious meal right there.
I love it.
That's one of my favorites.
But yeah,
but a lot of people make it a lot harder than what it is.
And like we said earlier,
that's probably the meat companies
adding all these extras to it,
and hyping it, making it something that it's not,
but it's very easy and it's very inexpensive.
Yeah, yeah.
And I mean, it's not just the meat companies,
it's cultural.
Cultural.
There's just
this hardened idea that this is what it is.
And so, you know, it's people like you
that are changing that perspective.
So thank you for that, man.
Thank you, bro.
Appreciate it.
And you're an inspiration.
I can't wait for you to get that phone call.
I wanna see what you're gonna be doing next year,
and I'm excited for you, man.
Thank you, bro.
I wanna come down and visit you guys in Costa Rica.
Oh, you should.
You're supposed to,
and then we end up coming down here,
so I know.
We gotta make that happen somehow.
I'd love to do that.
My friend Charlie Knowles
is gonna be moving down there soon.
Yeah.
He's a meditation teacher.
I should connect you to him too.
Oh, nice.
I don't know what part of Costa Rica it is, but.
Probably where we are.
That's like the big, hippy zone where we're living.
Oh, it is?
I thought the whole country is a big hippy zone.
Ours is like the concentration of hippies
where we are right there.
Is it?
Yeah.
All right, man.
I like it.
Thanks.
A hippie in the NFL.
Gotta do it, man.
Right on.
(man chuckling)
All right, man.
Well, thanks for dropping by.
All the kind of books and references that we made
throughout these conversation
will be in the show notes on the episode page
at ritual.com for this episode,
so go there and check that out,
and dig in,
and pull that thread,
and go on your own journey with all this stuff, man.
Right?
All right.
Cool.
I think we did it.
Yeah.
How you feel?
Feel good?
That was good, man.
Hey, this is a good interview.
You have to have me back on one second time.
Anytime, man.
Anytime.
I would love to have you back on.
I'd love to have you back on
after you're back and playing,
and come and share what that's all about,
what's that like.
All right.
We could do that.
No problem, man.
Cool, man.
All right.
Peace.
Plants.
(upbeat instrumental music)